hey everyone dear volo here and in
today's video we are finally wrapping up
the absolutely fantastic series that is
tatsuki fujimoto's chainsaw man first
off i'll be full on serious right now
during points of the series early on i
was wondering where exactly the hype
around this series actually was as it
kind of felt just like every other
battle type shonen that was out there
but gradually as i've moved further and
further into the story it's become
extremely apparent that tatsuki fujimoto
is an absolute beast the man is an utter
creative genius the way he structures
the parts of his story early on so that
it comes back and hits in a completely
and utterly different way than expected
is freaking ridiculous so please like
i'm begging you right now if you don't
know what's about to happen you have to
sit back relax and prepare yourselves
physically mentally and like stuff it
even spiritually as we dive into the
final and most insane arc with so many
damn twists and turns it left me
questioning the reality of pretty much
everything this here is the control
devil arc from tatsuki fujimoto's
chainsaw man and the final arc of the
first part of this series
previously on the life of our favorite
melon grabbing boy our main character
denji ended up facing against his best
friend and someone who over time ended
up becoming someone like a brother to
him aki who was actually morphed into
the gun theme and sadly as we know denji
ended up killing aki at the end of the
battle there but obviously there were
things that were said to us throughout
parts of the gandible arc that haven't
exactly come true yet which i'm hoping
do not come true like apparently dingy's
going to kill power but you know we're
going to find out as we get into this
arc here but anyway sit back and enjoy
so after receiving the money from aki's
well dingy and power rent a smaller
apartment with a lovely view then spend
the rest on delicious food and video
games one night dingy goes out to grab
an ice cream and also a rice ball for
power after purchasing some he sits on a
bench and finishes it then noting the
word winner on the ice cream stick he
thinks the words i killed aki and
immediately vomits
laying down now he thinks of how he has
constantly felt confused and unhappy
since aki's death he begins to speak to
pochita but before he can say anything
makima appears touching his hands and
telling him that his hands are cold she
tells him to stand up then she complies
still in a confused saddened state over
his brother's death makima then invites
stingy to her apartment for some tea to
warm up now they're inviting dingy
inside the two are instantly swarmed
with a mini cutas pet doggos makima
briefly pampers the dogs pissing them
and talking to them excitedly before
going on to ask dingy what kind of tea
he'd like as she continues to do on her
dogs with treats and adorable belly rubs
dingy watching her thinks on how much
calmer and happier he feels he thanks
her for it and she begins to pet him
makima then reminds denji that she had
offered him any one wish for defeating
the gandevol after considering what he
wants for a moment denji sadly states
that he wants to be treated as one of
her dogs
sitting there mahima asks denji to
elaborate on his desire to which he
explains that he no longer wishes to
think for himself as the growth of
relationships and responsibilities in
his life has led to an overwhelming
amount of grief and regret in his
decisions as such he feels placing all
of his decisions in makima's hands will
allow him to live a relaxed guiltless
life makima asks him if he is certain of
his choice with injury responding with a
half-hearted thumbs up not gonna lie
this was the moment i realized that my
boy gonda messed up real bad here like i
paused and honestly did not want to
scroll my screen down for the next few
minutes while reading this part just an
absolute anticipation of what this
absolute hoe was about to do to our
boy's heart anyway anyway the control
freak tests to new authority by asking
genji to perform several dog-like tricks
to which denji follows age and is pit on
the head as a reward he thinks of how
happy he is suddenly there is a knock at
the door makima reveals that she had
invited power earlier on then she asks
why however makima reminds him not to
think denji responds with a wolf and
makima guides him to the front door then
orders him to open it so that she can
kill power denji responds with another
wolf before pausing in sudden confusion
makima continues guiding denji to the
door as he blusters and asks her if
she's joking she ignores his hesitation
as she once again orders him to open the
door slowly denji moves towards the
handle thinking about how power would be
holding a cake on the other side as he
opens the door he questions why he
assumed she'd be holding a cave before
remembering the next day was in fact his
birthday looking into the corridor he
sees power standing in the hallway
holding a cake before either having time
to react makima points her finger at
power and says the word bang
power's torso is completely obliterated
then she looks on in shock and silence
as power's head falls between her legs
onto the floor mahima takes dingy's hand
telling him they are cold again and
ordering him back inside then she begins
to sweat profusely as he asks to speak
but no words will come out mahima closes
the door on power's body and leads dingy
back to the couch still in shock dingy
shakily asks makima if he is in a dream
makima leans over to rest her head on
his lap before she begins laughing
hysterically
honestly this freaking panel here she's
such a home man i saw this panel months
before i even started reading chainsaw
man and i just assumed that this was
going to be a happy moment like i think
anyone would think just looking at this
panel like it looks super happy from an
outside perspective but now after
actually getting the context around the
situation i'm just mortified at the pure
evilness of this damn witch and also you
guys ready for this revelation makima
demands that dingy take off his shirt
hesitating she reminds him of his
subservience and he proceeds lying back
down on his lap she begins to speak
playing with dingy's chord as she does
so she explains that dingy's promise to
bachita was in fact a contract desiring
to break that contract makima explains
she set about giving him everything he
wanted before snatching it away
she explains that by giving him food a
job and a family she would allow him to
attain a new level of normalcy before
destroying it she then informs him that
any happiness of normalcy he experiences
from then on will be orchestrated by her
with the express purpose of eventually
destroying it when denji asks why she
says that the time has come for you to
atone for your sins
elaborating mahima explains that she
looked into denji's past and saw his
repressed memories the hidden ones
behind the door that bachita ordered him
not to open she explains that denji had
the actual truth from himself in order
to be able to live a normal life the
truth was that he actually murdered his
father she goes on further stating that
denji killed his abusive and alcoholic
father in self-defense and that the
claims of suicide were merely created by
the mafia so that denji would inherit
his debts mahima tells denji that by
opening the door and accepting his past
he had accepted that he was unworthy of
a normal happy life she reminds him that
the same occurred with aki and power
though denji was warned not to and the
other options were available he
ultimately opened the door and accepted
their deaths
machima kneels down and asks the child
like dingy whether he believes he
deserves a normal life with him sadly
responding no
now flashing forward to the next morning
everything seems normal as mucky
mccalmly eats breakfast and dingy lies
motionless on her couch she then gets
dressed and guides stenchy outside into
the corridor there a number of demons
many of whom are dingy's deceased allies
kneel in front of them makima explains
that they were all followers of the
chainsaw devil whom put their lives on
their line to protect it waiting for the
day of resurrection as she says this the
building is suddenly breached by a devil
hunter group named the anti-machima
squad led by the old lovable fart
kishibe mahima is gunned down and killed
as a number of devil hunters slip their
throats in order to suddenly summon the
hell devil who they asked to kill makima
and banish her to hell however hearing
this makima commands dingy to save her
which causes his intestines to burst out
of his chest and throttle him as the
hunters slowly die outside the building
the hell devil emerges now in a flaming
centre-like form dingy standing atop the
corpses of the anti-machima squad pulls
his cord and transforms into the
chainsaw devil in an instant he loops
outside slicing the hell devil into many
clean-cut pieces of hell shishimi
as the blood and guts rain down he
stands tall in a darker more muscular
form with multiple arms and blades
spawning from him i honestly i freaking
love this berserk level body armor that
he's gone on right now it looks so
freaking badass fujimoto is actually a
base when it comes to drawing this kind
of like dirty stuff if you know what i
mean that's just how i feel right now
it's so dirty and grimy it's so clean
dingy stands above the decapitated hell
devil as one of the devil hunters gives
blood to revive it as he does a door
opens above them and the hell devil's
hand emerges crushing dingy like a bug
transporting them to hell from a nearby
building makima watches commenting on
the outcome to kishibe who now has a gun
pointed at her aruhid makima notes that
shooting her would be useless as she has
a deal with the prime minister of japan
to transfer all of the damage taken by
her to a random japanese citizen hence
how she has managed to revive each time
so far that she has died asking why she
remains calm even with the chainsaw
devil being cast into hell makima
responds that it will return to save her
kashibe in horror asks mahima what she
truly is to which she responds she's a
fan of the chainsaw devil as she talks
the chainsaw devil tears through various
devils in hell she explains that within
hell the chainsaw man is known as the
hero of hell when it hears a cry for
help the chainsaw devil moves in
eviscerating every devil it faces friend
or foe mahima then explains the ultimate
power of the chainsaw devil any devil
consumed by it has his names erased from
existence faced against such an
unstoppable opponent all other devils
either despise fear or worship the
chainsaw devil so this x actually goes
explain i guess why bean was such a
fanboy as he literally worshipped the
chainsaw devil and i love you being rest
in peace brother anyway kishida
expresses doubt that such a power could
even exist however mahima retorts by
asking him what he knows of the
holocaust it is then revealed that
kishibe alongside humanity at large have
no knowledge of nazism could help japan
always bringing up the 40s like it's
just yesterday mahiba continues
explaining that almost every major
crisis faced by humanity will all erase
from existence by the chainsaw devil she
goes on to explain that even universal
constants such as humanity's sixth sense
and the four possible conclusions other
than death which honestly i have no idea
what that is someone who's like into
that culture or something let me know
down in the comment section below at the
end of life we're also erased mahima
elaborates explaining that she cannot
even remember these things though she
remembers the fights between their
devils and the chainsaw devil kishibe
asks mahima's intentions with the devil
to which she reveals the true nature of
her own ability to control any being
that she believes is lesser than herself
therefore if she were able to defeat the
chainsaw devil in combat she would be
able to control it and use its powers to
create a world without pain war or death
kishibe asks what she would do if she
lost to which she replies that she is a
fan of the chainsaw devil and it would
be a happy honorable end turning back to
the window makima notes dingy's return
as the door to hell reopens and the
chainsaw devil emerges showered in blood
kishibe continues to stand off with
mahima as he stares her down she wants
him to stand back as she turns to
prepare to face denji in an instant then
she bursts through the wall and slices
makima to pieces before turning and
looking to kashibe suddenly dingy hears
someone somewhere say their words save
me and immediately leaves elsewhere at a
burger restaurant a group of employees
sing and dance to an irritated customer
kabini now an employee there delivers
the food to their table attempting to
dance along awkwardly she is taken aside
by her boss who chastises her for her
forced smile and verbal tick of saying
ah as other employees join in kabini
quietly mutters the words save me the
staff suddenly turn to see denji looming
over them greeting kabini with var the
customer attempts to flee but is
instantly decapitated by denji then she
looks at the restaurant's menu and
remembers an earlier request to pachita
to try hamburgers sitting at a nearby
table he attempts to order a hamburger
speaking through a series of chainsaw
revs the restaurant's mascot is
decapitated as he attempts to contact
the devil hunters suddenly deciphering
denji's revs kabini and the other
employees begin to prepare his order as
they sing and dance with panic on their
faces then she moves his arms shuffling
in time with their dancing kabini is
ordered to deliver the food to his table
however as she does she trips and spills
the food all over him looking up at the
annoyed dingy kabini asks for another
hamburger as the employees repeat their
dance now with tears streaming down
their faces kabini's boss begins to
shout at her blaming her for their
demise before he is too decapitated as
kabini again attempts to deliver the
order she trips and falls spilling the
food identically to the first time as
she lays on the floor terrified she
begins screaming
her disbelieving co-workers begin to
accuse denji of playing an elaborate
televised prank instantly though he is
decapitated as kabini begins to pick up
the ingredients off the floor and
reconstruct the burger genji takes a
bite before grimacing with disapproval
remembering another password of dingies
to go on a date with a girl he grabs
kabini and carries her outside then
stopping in an ice cream van dingy
shreds it to pieces before requiring a
pair of ice creams for the two of them
kabini continues to sob crying out that
the ice cream doesn't taste of anything
a devil hunter then appears and
threatens dingy but is instantly
eviscerated as denji turns kabini
towards a dance dance revolution machine
and orders her to dance after commenting
that she has no money then she then
shreds an atm and kabini begins to play
out of fear as she continues dancing
dingy actually leaves he then arrives on
top of a rooftop and surveying her
surroundings notices makima is nearby
she comments on him noticing her as she
commands her allies to emerge suddenly
denji stands surrounded by seven devil
hunters all commenting on their love for
makima and desire to date her as the
first full wager a date with mahima for
killing dingy the other three are
revealed to be katana man rezay and kwan
shi they all each pledge their
allegiance to makima with the katana man
commenting that she has saved their
lives over and over again as makima
agrees to the bet a date in return for
killing dng
which is you know like a complete role
reversal of what was going on with denji
earlier on so i absolutely love that i
think it's quite cool quirky
as machima stands amongst a group of
human devil hybrids she elaborates on
their true nature they are not humans
devils or fiends but another type of
creature that was erased by the chainsaw
devil's powers yet still somehow
continues to exist she explains that
whilst fighting them in hell the
chainsaw devil disappeared and appeared
on earth as pochita and they have been
searching for him since
as denji yawns makima commands her
agents to attack each agent pulls out
their weapon transforming themselves
into their hybrid forms and lunging at
dingy as each makes contact with him
they are blown back by the force of him
leaping forward crashing through
skyscrapers while slicing through quan
she and the broadsword hybrid as they
land in an apartment complex dingy
kneels over kwonji's tatted body
clutching his severed heads behind him
the katana man appears attempting to
slice through dingy however he is
unsuccessful as it is shown then she was
able to decapitate him without taking
any damage himself makima looks on
calmly exclaiming that the conflict
appears unwinnable standing on the floor
below denji the flamethrower hybrid
flies into the ceiling causing a massive
explosion to burst through the building
as denji leaps backwards to the safety
onto another building the whip hybrid
appears and slashes into him her attacks
seem to have little impact however as
rezay blasts through the building and
grabs dengy carrying him up into the sky
flipping
denzel decapitates resay before he is
impaled by a spear thrown by the spear
hybrid stunned in midair mahima takes
the momentary days to blast injury
repeatedly pointing at him and stating
bang as each hit launches him further
and further into the sky as denji is
pushed out of the atmosphere and into
space making the comments wondering how
long he could hold his breath
reaching inside of himself though denji
rips out his own heart and flings it
towards the ground as the heart begins
to burn up upon re-entry into the
atmosphere denzi's body begins to reform
around it until it is fully formed still
forming dingy launches his chains across
the city grappling onto mahima the whip
flamethrower and spare hybrids then
hoisting them up into the air they each
express a moment of shock before they
are too torn apart by dengi's chainsaws
flashing over to kabini whose dance
dance revolution is coming to an end she
stands tired and sweating atop the
machine before exclaiming that she
happily got a perfect score her head
turns to the side as she looks over
terrified at chainsaw man who's now
sitting atop the step across from kabini
kabini stands confused asking to the air
why she was dancing as makima answers
from above her prompting kabini and
chainsaw man to look up at her sitting
on the roof above makima goes on to
state that in total she has been killed
26 times by chainsaw man and yet she
questioned why it was that he continued
to refuse to eat her the corpse of the
devil hunter whom the chainsaw man had
killed prior begins to move being pulled
up to mahima as a chain from her body
attaches itself to him and joins makima
floating above several dozen other
chained men kabini starts to show denial
saying twice that she had nothing to do
with the current situation before makima
cuts her off saying that she did indeed
have a major role in the current events
currently unfolding and that the fear of
chainsaw man had grown weaker this
prompts kabini to look over at chainsaw
man as blood begins to leak from his
body making mistakes that she liked
humans the same as they like dogs in the
sense that to her they were loyal easily
manageable smart yet stupid and they all
loved her a television show and the
window of a city shop begins
broadcasting the news stating that
chainsaw man had just defeated the gun
devil he goes on to state that the news
of the gun devil's defeat was being met
with a praise and shock across the
entire globe the broadcaster continues
praising denzi's ability to get up over
and over again despite his many injuries
and then switches to a woman who's
stating that the chainsaw man was a hero
and a man who explains how dingy had
fought the dole devil's army and thanks
him for allowing to escape a woman yells
into a mic that she had seen him riding
a shark through the streets as he fought
the typhoon devil a woman exclaims that
he had saved her on a train a man states
that dingy had protected him from the
bat devil and finally another woman says
that he had rescued her at a rest stop
as people are out on the street
celebrating chainsaw man chanting his
name the broadcaster tells watchers to
go outside and see what's happening for
themselves and that everyone should join
together to cheer them on even more
which is obviously hella dope for our
boy but at the same time time dude's
getting mad debuffed right now if you
understand what's going on because with
him more and more blood is shown pulling
around him mahi mistakes that the humans
cheering him on were eating away at him
and contrasting the power given to him
by all the devils who feared him a
chained angel then appears floating
above makima as she uses his power stay
team usage 1 000 years summoning a black
red spear as makima asks if kabini has
enough strength to avoid her coming
attack believing that dingy would
attempt to save her a black circle
appears in the air in front of makima
with three large humanoid figures
appearing in the air around the growing
circle at equal distances the faces of
kibani and chainsaw man are shown bathed
in light as makima launches the spear at
cabine chainsaw man moves in front of
her pushing her away as the spear passes
through his torso his blood is shown
gushing out of his body as he collapses
face first onto the ground mucky massage
as the crowd continues to cheer for our
ever weakening chainsaw man skipping
away power is shown sleeping on a mess
of blood and organs complaining as
pochita nudges her with its pore she
opens her eyes and turns her head
towards pachito who tells her to wake up
power initially confused quickly makes
the connection that he was pachita
pachita smiles at her realization before
telling her that he wanted her to save
denji he tells her that she truly wasn't
dead as she was currently the blood that
dingy had drunk from her before and that
if nothing was done she would soon
disappear vegeta asks for her to eat
some of him and revive as a full-fledged
devil to which our freaking girl like
holy [__] i couldn't live without power
being around any longer happily obliges
as dingy is her best friend back in
reality makima moves down onto the
ground with around a dozen members of
public safety lined up behind her
chainsaw man begins to get up on his
hands and knees then as he points his
head forwards power suddenly ejects from
his mouth in the form of the blood vein
power laughs as she points towards
makima which causes blood weapons to
suddenly push out from within the bodies
of her and all of the public safety
members power yells that she is the
strongest as a bloodied machima uses
angel's ability to create a sword worth
of a hundred years power then uses a
move she calls thousand terra blood rain
showering mahima with several dozen
blood weapons as they shoot down from
above she gloats and spouts nonsense as
mahima is continually impaled like that
she herself was the first president as
the barrage of weapons stops makima
calls on the zombie devil which appears
behind her and turns the deceased
members of the public safety into
zombies these zombies rush power
grabbing onto her and biting her she
screams out in pain as making me shoot
off her arm with a finger gun makima
asks a bleeding power how she was still
alive with power refusing to answer as
she lunges back grabbing chainsaw man
and proclaiming him as her own makima
asks for power to give her chainsaw man
under the threat of death stating that
she let power be her pet again if she
gave him over
stupidly power fumbles the bag moving
behind chainsaw man and lifting him up
before stating that she had in fact
captured him but cheetah is shown in a
state of shock and confused as power
happily states the glory was all hers
while power stands there gripping dingy
makim asks for power to give her chains
or man anu ahead power looks on her time
with dingy thinking back on when they
first met when he first saved her from
the bat devil when they bathed together
and when they gave aki a meal they'd
cook together our queen though defies
that ho as blood weapons shoot out of
makima forcing her weak ass to her knees
power runs off with denji screaming and
asking why she was disobeying makima
despite the fact that victory was
impossible she comes across two devil
hunters which call on the mantis devil
one of its arms shooting up from the
ground and slicing her on the side
before she kills the two now stumbling
as a horde of zombies suddenly rained
down upon her we see a young dirty power
running down and stumbling on a road she
looks at her hand reminiscing on her
belief that all lives were equally
trivial that her life and a stranger's
life was nothing to ever be said over
and that dingy was an exception to that
belief screaming out that dingy couldn't
die in reality a wounded power bleeding
crawls towards an alleyway dragging
chainsaw man along with her power slowly
moves closer to the dumpster crawling
inside as she realizes the reason she
actually cared about denji's life was
because he was her first ever friend
a human dingy and theme power are shown
on the dumpster together the letter
happily shouting his name before hugging
him power tells dingy that she was able
to save him with dingy responding that
he was fine and not in need of saving as
he'd already accomplished all of his
dreams going on to say that his life
with power had been like a dream
comparing to the time that he had with
the mafia he tells you again that he was
fine and that nothing good would ever
occur in his life again power yells at
dingy though calling him a dummy asking
him if he truly missed her so much that
he couldn't do anything he responds that
he did and power calls him a fool for
not wanting to do so
she goes on to tell him that devils went
to hell after dying on earth and that
when they died they would most likely be
enemies if they ever met again and
despite this he needs to find whatever
she has become and befriend it to turn
it back into the real power so that they
can be buddies again power then forms a
contract with denji giving him the last
of her blood in return for finding the
blood devil again dingy wakes and the
dumpster bolting upright as he shouts
for power he bends over clutching his
heart as he thinks of her
his grieving though is interrupted as
kishibe is revealed to be sitting down
beside the dumpster as dingy turns to
look at him koshiba asks if he was
either dingy or the chainsaw and states
if he was truly dingy then he would help
give him some way to escape from makima
dinji stands silent for a moment before
showing kishibe the peace symbol as a
way to prove it's our goofy ass boy
koshiba leads denshi and kabini into an
underground safe house kibbeny comments
on how having witnessed mahima's attack
she will likely be hunted down and asks
kashibe if she'll ever be able to
contact her family again he tells her
probably not to which she responds with
relief which leaves dingy surprised but
kabini explains that she no longer has
to contact her family which kind of
makes her happy
as the two sit kibendi begins to cry
explaining her fears of death and
telling denji that she is jealous of his
reincarnation abilities then she replies
that though he is physically fine he has
an emotional wreck and is coming to
terms with the fact that he had lived
his entire life and subservience to
others never making any significant
choices of his own kabini responds that
such a life a life full of hardships and
unhappiness is normal stunning him as he
stares at her in shock he comments on
how he wanted to be normal to which she
responds with confusion
suddenly dingy's attention is drawn to a
nearby tv on which news reports
discussing the chainsaw man are playing
the tv discusses the chainsaw man's
heroic deeds showing a number of people
cheering and celebrating him dingy
watches and stunned silence quietly
whispering that's me to himself
he exclaims that everyone was praising
him before holding up a hand to his face
holding back tears as he shouted that he
was popular watching as a girl on the
screen waved his sign asking for
chainsaw man to go out with her sitting
back in the armchair behind dingy
kishibe opens his eyes before telling
dinji to quiet him down then she tells
him that he was tired of eating things
like bread and jam for breakfast and
instead wanted to eat steak every day in
its place he cries about how he can't
and shouldn't wish for such things as he
collapses onto his hands and knees in
front of kishibe saying how he wanted to
have five no 10 girlfriends and that he
wanted to have lots of demonetization
stuff dingy slowly pulls himself back up
before exclaiming that he wanted to be
chainsaw man for those reasons because
she may sit silently for a moment before
telling denji that makima would find and
kill him if he attracted too much
attention telling him that the next time
he entered his hybrid form would be the
time she would kill him at some point
later in the night dingy continues to
watch the television as kashibe and
kabini sleep he tells himself that he
definitely wanted to become the chainsaw
man and asks himself how he was going to
kill makima he knows that she wasn't
someone he could win against without a
plan and tries to think about some way
he could defeat her his mind is soon
filled with the memories of his time
with public safety as he thinks back on
the encounter with the darkness devil
his first time meeting bame and his
fight against santa claus denzi's mind
is then filled with the memories of
makima with images of her face appearing
from when she told him she'd grant him
any wish if she'd killed the gun devol
when she introduced him to her pet dogs
when she laughed in his lap after he
asked her if killing power was a dream
when she fed him her blood during the
fight against santa claus when she
listened to his heart when she told him
what he would be able to eat for
breakfast if he became her dog when she
licked a lollipop before giving it to
him as an indirect kiss and when she
told him that she liked some boy named
dingy
dingy looks down and defeat muttering to
himself that he was the worst and that
even after everything makima had done to
him he still couldn't help but like her
at some point in the future during the
day time dingy in his hybrid form sits
upon a cross in the graveyard with
mahima the katana man rezay quan chi the
whip hybrid the spear hybrid the berserk
hybrid the flamethrower hybrid and
several dozen members of public safety
walking up to him along a dirt path
makima walks up to denji as she takes
note of his weaker form before asking if
he finally came to die for her then she
gets up from the cross before asking
makima if there would be any crappy
movies in her vision of a utopian world
making her realize that it was in fact
dingy there and not the true chainsmore
man form she responds that she believed
it would be for the best if bad movies
were erased from the world to which
dingy says that he has no choice but to
kill her maki massaged before telling
dingy that everything about him was not
fit for the chainsaw man four crows are
shown flying up into the sky as denji
spins up his chainsaws facing makima
while she approaches him along with the
hybrids and many other members of public
safety zombies suddenly come up from the
graves around dingy as the zombie devil
appears now also behind makima the
zombies begin to rush at dingy from all
sides then she sticks his arms into the
ground shooting his chains down and
wrapping them around a large chunk of
earth before pushing them up launching
several zombies and a massive rock into
the air behind them pulling the chunk of
ground in front of him and throwing it
towards makima katana man and the
longsword hybrid leap into the ear both
slicing the chunk of land and cutting it
down into several smaller chunks the two
now vulnerable in the air watch as denji
appears from behind the debris before
cutting them both with his chainsaws
this spear hybrid leaps up from behind
genji before skewering him with his
chest rize and the whip hybrid both fly
towards denji yelling out a battle cry
as he spins in the air slicing rezay
with one of the chainsaws on his arms
and cutting the whip in spare hybrids
with the one on his legs dingy and the
slumped bodies of all the hybrids he
just dunked on then fall to the ground
konji appears from behind dingy shooting
him with her arrows these zombies rush
in grabbing him as more and more jump
atop him quickly forming a large pile as
he becomes trapped beneath them makima
and the flamethrower hybrid watched the
zombies where they flamethrower noting
how denji was much weaker than he was
before makima says that this was because
the entire world was embracing chainsaw
man and spreading his image even going
as far as turning him into a
merchandised character and that there
was no longer a need to fear him still
they flown through a hybrid points his
arms towards the pile before shooting it
with his flames torching it as all of
these zombies begin to burn makima quan
shi and the flamethrower all stand for a
moment as they watch the flames the
flamethrower hybrid yells out in
surprise as two chains shoot out from
the flaming mass each wrapping around a
grave marking behind him before denji
retracts them launching himself towards
and cutting the flamethrower hybrid in
half as kwonchi blocks him with her arms
then she slices at her and manages to
decapitate kwon she but still several
more arrows pierce him a bloody dingy
falls on his knees then onto his back as
makima stands above him looking down on
him before pointing her finger at her
left palm and saying bang as she shoots
a hole through it she holds her bleeding
palm above denji's mouth letting the
blood spilling from it fall into his
mouth she then demands that he wake up
as she wanted to trade blows with him so
that she could kill him personally as a
bunch of public safety members float up
behind makima chains appear moving out
from their torsos and connecting them to
her
making the pulls on dingy's chest cord
gracing him before he immediately
decapitates her her head flies off but
due to the chains instead the head of
one of the public safety members
suddenly flies off as machima's head
moves back to her body then she tries to
strike at her again with his left arm
missing as makima dodges and punches him
in the face knocking him back but denji
still manages to slice open her chest
with his right arm then again the injury
is transferred to another public safety
member as makima once again regenerates
she unleashes a flurry of punches
consecutively hitting dingy in the chest
as blood sprays from his mouth though he
still somehow manages to slice her head
off a headless makima kicks dingy in the
chin knocking him back as her head
begins to return to her neck as makima's
head reattaches she punches one of
dingy's arms off destroying it she aims
to punch him again as a chainsaw appears
from dingy's leg kicking her and slicing
her in half makima's torso and lower
half quickly reattach as she turns
around punching a hole straight through
denji's torso she swings around to the
front grabbing onto a chunk of guts
spilling out of him before punching him
again tearing through his chest as both
of his arms are ripped off oh my god the
actual brutality of that sentence when i
finally when i finally said it correctly
was mental machiama holds on to dingy's
armless corpse from the handle of his
head pulling out pachita with her right
arm as she slowly pulls pochita out from
his body she tells dingy that denji was
not the chainsaw man
she asks how she could possibly get him
to completely give up on living and how
she could ever possibly get chainsaw man
back then she responds by spitting blood
on her face she continues by saying that
chainsaw man didn't wear clothes or
speak and that he only made a mess out
of everything he did she says that even
with all of dingy's ignorance he was
still chosen as the chainsaw man and
that since he was standing between
mahima and him he must die makima fully
rips pochita from denji's chest blood
spurting from his wounds as he coughs up
blood his head then falls back onto the
ground with makima standing above him
staring down at his motionless corpse
makima walks through the graveyard
stepping through the various bodies of
deceased public safety members as she
reaches down and picks up a pack of
cigarettes from the inside of one of the
suits jackets okay i'm not even giving
this fake ass arky wannabe right now the
time of day she's trying to smoke and
she can't even handle one path like what
even is this anyway one puff andy puts
out the smoke before picking up pochito
and telling him that it was now the
second time she had ever defeated him
and that now he belong to her she tells
him that they'd be together forever now
that eat a lot together sleep together
and live happy together forever
several feet behind makima the goat
himself actually managed to play the
silly witch denji slowly stands up from
amongst the pile of corpses he slowly
walks over to makima and as she notices
them he takes out a normal chainsaw and
slices her down their freaking chest
makima gasps confused and shocked as
blood spews from her torso falling to
her knees as dingy now stands above her
in a complete role reversal then she
exclaims that makima had finally let her
guard down and tells her that he would
now be taking pochita back he reaches
down picking up pochetta as he says that
what he just did now was dangerous and
that he had used up all of the blood
power had given him from their contract
revealing how he had actually managed to
survive without his heart because
technically power was his heart and like
honestly i freaking love that soppy [__]
man tatsuki fujimoto had different with
that one mahima now bleeding from her
mouth and nose asks how dingy was alive
to which dingy responds that she had
actually been fighting pochita the
entire time as mahima continues to bleed
then she tells her that the chainsaw he
had just cut her with was made out of
the blood that he had got from power and
that he was making it run a muck inside
of her makima says this is hardly enough
too to which deinji cuts her off and
says that he didn't believe he could
truly kill her was such a cheap trick
and honestly you guys are not ready for
what is about to happen like at all i
mean adult you have no idea what is
about to happen unless you have already
read it you have no idea like you don't
even you don't even have this in the
most foreign region of your brain that
this idea would happen at the moment so
just be [__] really this is about to
happen okay okay
a van pulls up behind denji leading him
to happily exclaim that master kishibe
was there to pick them up he tells
makima he's sorry before
later on a shot of tokyo is shown with
various citizens shown to be going about
their day the scene transitions to night
and the exterior of a run-down apartment
building with kishibe's van parked
outside inside a room kishibe complains
that his back hurt before asking dingy
if he was ready and as dingy says that
he was kishibe tells him that from there
onward it was personally up to him he
tells him the innocent people were dying
as they speak and that it would be best
if dingy could finish as quickly as
possible yet dingy says that he'll be
going at his own leisurely pace kishibe
then tells him one last thing he didn't
believe that what dingy was about to do
would truly work and that he should be
prepared for failure and death denji
tells him that he himself was the one
who came up with the idea so he was
already prepared kishibe leaves as he
tells denji that he'd be back by again
if he was still alive and tells him to
not die as out of everyone he'd ever met
dingy was the most suited for being a
devil hunter i freaking love that old
man the door to the apartment closes as
dingy talks to himself and walking into
the refrigerator mumbling that he was
very hungry he pulls a small box out of
the meat stacked fridge because you know
gotti good for real then stingy says
that even after everything that happened
he still liked makima he begins to cook
saying that he couldn't forgive makima
after everyone she'd killed he says that
because of that he'd share the burdens
of her sins with her and asks himself
how he would truly do that he toys with
the idea of latching themselves onto a
bomb and performing a double suicide
before countering it with the fact that
all previous physical attacks had no
effect on her but says that that fact is
what read him to realise how to beat her
and how to become one with her
dingy then finishes preparing his meal
which consists of a small bowl of white
rice miso soup and ginger fried meat and
onions then in the normal japanese style
he performs itadikimasu before taking a
sip of the miso soup and noting that it
was extremely good mmm very tasteful he
takes a bite of the ginger fried meat
and onions and says that it tastes
alright he begins to take a bite of the
rice as he notes that what he was
tasting was what makima tasted like if
you catch my damn drift oh my god i
couldn't stop laughing at this [__] when
i first read it like how well did
tatsuki fujimoto manage to hide that up
into the last line dingy the only way he
gets rid of makima is by eating her i
love it it's so good later on now and in
a park kishibe sits on a bench drinking
as then she walks towards him with all
seven of makima's dogs and meowi on his
head then she sits down next to kishibe
on the bench letting a few kids come and
play with their dogs a young girl then
approaches them and says doggies dingy
tells kishibe that he had eaten all of
makima and that she hadn't revived
kishibe then asked stenshi how he had
killed her despite the fact that attacks
had no effect on her to which danger
responds that he honestly didn't want to
hurt mahima that him eating her and
becoming one with her wasn't even an
attack but rather love i guess
kishibe tells him that he probably just
ended up accidentally finding a way
around her contract before asking dingy
how he managed to attack makimo without
her detecting him dingy explains that
makima only perceived people through his
sense of smell and because of that he
bit that mahima only saw chainsaw man
the entire time he'd known her and never
truly took notice of him which is
freaking deep bro like who knows if they
after their chainsaw clout for real the
young girl moves closer to pet creampuff
leaving denji to tell her that he and
kishibe were having a top secret
conversation and that she needed to beat
it the young girl walks up to denji
before biting his finger quickly leading
denji to recognize her bite as maki miz
the young girl looks up at denji showing
him that her eyes also have the same
target-like pattern as maki miz kishibe
tells denji that the young girl had been
recently discovered in china and that he
had stolen her oh yes of course typical
old man stealing a child he tells him
that the young girl wasn't makima but
just the control devil and that no
memories from makima were in the girl he
says that if they left the young girl in
the hands of the bureau she'd inevitably
become just like makima again kishibe
ends off by telling dingy that he would
be leaving the reborn control devil in
his hands as he was going to be really
busy for the foreseeable future then she
asks the young girl what her name was to
which she responds that her name was
nayuta then she sighs and asks her if
she wanted to do anything other than eat
meat
she responds that she wanted to eat
sliced bread prompting dingy to say that
she was a pretty inexpensive devil to
keep around he then walks back to his
apartment walking the dogs with him as
naouta rides on his back back at his
apartment the two eat some sliced bread
before falling asleep with naota
sleeping in denji's futon while dingy
sleeps directly on the floor using one
of the dogs as a palahoo binji begins to
dream and inside of his dream he finds
himself holding pochita as the two sit
within the shed they lived in during
denji's time within the mafia
pochetta tells denji that his dream was
to be hugged by someone and his strength
made it hard for anyone to want to hug
him patrita thanks denji for making his
dream come true then goes on to ask
dingy if he could fulfill the control
devil's dreams too a dream of building
an equal relationship with other people
makima had this dream but couldn't
accomplish it since she only formed
relationships through the power of fear
and because of that grew yearning for
something like a family over time
bushida tells dinji that he wants him to
make the dream come true for naota to
which then she asks how and patrita
tells him that it could be done through
giving her lots and lots of hugs which
obviously just correlates to a good
upbringing difficult japanese monkey
could have ended in a hella sus way but
yeah obviously because of her previous
upbringing with the bureau she turned
into the manipulative control freak that
she was and at the moment she's just a
normal control freak but finally as we
start off the new series at some point
in the future a large deformed devil
rampages through the streets of tokyo
chasing innocent civilians several
rumors about the chainsaw man i heard
spreading that killing devils was just
his hobby that he only saved cute girls
if he was truly a human and that he was
just a high school student but standing
there against the crowd we find dingy
face to face with the approaching devil
he stands alone wearing his high school
uniform and beginning to pull the kill
switch on his chest
damn man honestly what a fantastic
series chainsaw man has been over the
last like nine or so videos that we have
discussed this entire series on my
channel i haven't thoroughly thoroughly
enjoyed it and i never expected it to
end the way that it actually has and i
can't thank you all enough for not
spoiling me down in the comment section
below because i read pretty much every
single comment i'm super surprised that
no one has gone ahead and spoiled me on
the outcome of the series anyway
obviously if you have enjoyed you know
like this video and want me to cover
more stuff in the future then let me
know down in the comment section below
what kind of like manga or anime you
want me to go over i bought house
paradise so i'm probably gonna start
reading that soon and obviously go over
there probably is the uh anime releases
to be honest there's bleach and juicy
kaizen and a bunch of other series that
i want to get over or get like out in
the meantime before the anime starts
releasing for them as well so you know
look forward to those over the next few
weeks and months obviously the luffy v
kaido battle was going to be the next
video that i dropped which is going to
come out in a week from now hopefully
all things going well but yeah obviously
if you have enjoyed this and want to see
more stuff just like it then hit that
subscribe button and uh you know also
leave a like on the video as it pushes
my stuff to a bunch of new amazing
people and you know it helps me grow on
youtube and i can't you know thank you
enough for hitting that like button if
you do hit it you know like cringy ass
thing and i hate saying it every single
video but it really does help me more
than you guys could actually possibly
imagine but anyway obviously if you guys
want to support me more than youtube in
general you can't have that remember one
you look cool icon next to your name or
you can go over and support me on
patreon where you'll get all of like my
explained videos for series and whatnot
kind of like a few hours to a day or two
earlier um and then you'll get like when
i do a full series in general like and
compilate it together you'll get that
you know like probably a month earlier
than my youtube channel will actually
get it if you're interested in that then
be sure to go check that out down in the
description below but anyway enough of
that for now spin your professional
degenerate diavolo and i will see you
all in a bit
bye